Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Perhaps the best part of being a computer
graphics researcher is creating virtual worlds
on a daily basis and computing beautiful simulations
in these worlds.
And what you see here is not one, but two
kinds of simulations.
One is a physics simulation that computes
how these objects move, and a light transport
simulation that computes how these objects
look.
In this video, we will strictly talk about
the physics simulation part of what you see
on the screen.
To simulate these beautiful phenomena, many
recent methods build on top of a technique
called the Material Point Method.
This is a hybrid simulation technique that
uses both particles and grids to create these
beautiful animations, however, when used by
itself, we can come up with a bunch of cases
that it cannot simulate properly.
One such example is cracking and tearing phenomena,
which has been addressed in this great paper
that we discussed earlier this year.
With this method, we could smash oreos, candy
crabs, pumpkins, and much, much more.
It even supported tearing this piece of bread
apart.
This already looks quite convincing, and in
this series, I always say, two more papers
down the line, and it will be improved significantly.
Today, we are going to have a Two Minute Papers
moment of truth, because this is from a followup
work by Joshuah Wolper, the first author of
the previous bread paper, and you can immediately
start holding on to your papers, because this
work is one of the finest I have seen as of
late.
With this, we can enrich our simulations with
anisotropic damage and elasticity.
So what does that mean exactly?
This means that it supports more extreme topological
changes in these virtual objects.
This leads to better material separation when
the damage happens.
For instance, if you look here on the right,
this was done by a previous method.
For the first sight, it looks good, there
is some bouncy behavior here, but the separation
line is a little too clean.
Let’s have a look at the new method!
Woo-hoo!
Now that’s what I am talking about!
Let’s have another look.
I hope you now see what I meant by the previous
separation line being a little too clean.
Remarkably, it also supports changing a few
intuitive parameters, like eta, the crack
propagation speed, which we can use to further
tailor the simulation to our liking.
Artists are going to love this.
We can also play with the Young modulus, which
describes the material’s resistance against
fractures.
On the left, it is quite low, and makes the
material tear apart easily, much like a sponge.
As we increase it bit, we get a stiffer material,
which gives us this glorious floppy behavior.
Let’s increase it even more, and see what
happens!
Yes, it is more resistant against damage,
however, in return, it gives us some more
vibrations after the break.
It is not only realistic, but it also gives
us the choice with these parameters to tailor
our simulation results to our liking.
Absolutely incredible.
Now then, if you have been holding on to your
papers so far, now squeeze that paper, because
previous methods were only capable of tearing
off a small piece, or only a strip of this
virtual pork, let’s see what this new work
will do.
Yes, it can also simulate peeling off an entire
layer.
Glorious!
But that’s not the only thing we can peel.
It can also deal with small pieces of this
mozzarella cheese.
I must admit that I have never done this myself,
so this will be the official piece of homework
for me, and for the more curious minds out
there after watching this video.
Let me know in the comments if it went the
same way in your kitchen as it did in the
simulation here!
You get extra credit if you post a picture
too.
And finally, if we tear this piece of meat
apart, you see that it takes into consideration
the location of the fibers, and the tearing
takes place not in an arbitrary way, but much
like in reality, it tears along the muscle
fibers.
So, how fast is it?
We still have to wait a few seconds for each
frame in these simulations.
None of them took too long, there is a fish
tearing experiment in the paper that went
very quickly, half a second for each frame
is a great deal, the pork experiment took
nearly 40 seconds for each frame, and the
most demanding experiments involved a lance
and bones.
Frankly, they were a little too horrific to
be included here, even for virtual bodies,
but if you wish to have a look, make sure
to click the paper in the video description.
But wait, are you seeing what I am seeing?
Those examples took more than 1000 times longer
to compute!
Goodness!
How can that be?
Look!
As you see here, in these cases, the delta-t-step
is extremely tiny, which means that we have
to advance the simulation with tiny-tiny time
steps that takes much longer to compute.
How tiny?
Quite!
In this case, we have to advance the simulation
one millionth of a second at a time.
The reason for this is that bones have an
extremely high stiffness, which makes this
method much less efficient.
And of course, you know the drill, two more
papers down the line, and this may run interactively
on a consumer machine at home.
So what’s the verdict?
Algorithm design.
A+.
Exposition, A+.
Quality of presentation A double plus.
And it’s still Mr. Wolper’s third paper
in computer graphics.
Unreal.
And we, researchers even get paid to create
beautiful works like this.
I also couldn’t resist creating a slow-motion
version of some of these videos, so if this
is something that you wish to see, make sure
to visit our Instagram page in the video
description for more.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!